[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
oh I got something so in Mexico when we
just were there none of the girls could
poop at all why were you eating carne
asada every day I don't know but I will
normally I eat a lot more vegetables
there's not a lot of vegetables the
Mexican cooking like there was fruit a
lot of fruit but there was a lot of
alcohol there was not a lot of vegetable
you get travel constipation because
that's a thing I don't get constipation
what happened is we would poop like
little pellets I mean I don't poop but
like if Steve's watching I don't poop
but like everyone was getting like
little pellets instead of that long
fibrous poop and then y'all got back and
everyone had diarrhea and I'm like I'm
not gonna get it all the girls were all
the texture and they're like oh my god
it's crazy and I'm like I'm not gonna
get it I haven't got any years I got it
like it started going in the middle of
mafia days if you watch that really
lasted to the away I'm like kill me kill
me [ __ ] you look a little
nervous
Nicky yeah exactly waiting for someone
to be like you look nervous like no I
just said times out times I would have
made everyone home I almost did like you
know and we had every report apart
because I cuz like a couple times
Brandon Nichkhun here or whatever I was
like come on outside thank you I almost
[ __ ] myself on there why almost [ __ ] on
their Bush on the front I have the
footage the video surveillance catechol
ID look I almost [ __ ] under I Wayne is
funny he was like pacing back and forth
on our driveway he's back and he's like
going like this and then you just see
him going whoo [ __ ] it he does so
oh yeah and look security cameras no
sound that's extra funny that's funny
[Laughter]
right when I was about to go like like
this as I bent over I think like my
stomach pushed the [ __ ] back in yeah
came in and I was like oh I don't have
to go anymore this long he went up and I
was like wait did I [ __ ] and then I had
to check my ass he did I was like it's
wet I was like it's wet and I was like
oh it's not poop it's wet
do you want like this so I see this view
and he just goes like this real quick
and he goes what he goes wait did you
did you touch her yeah I credit card in
my ass cuz already guarded where I was
that I was like I have so much
adrenaline I was like did I really [ __ ]
like I'm not sure and it was so slippery
in between the cheeks so I had to slip
it up and I was like oh my god that's
wet oh my god it's not did you touch her
butthole cuz like that dad remember you
we had a cupcake and you gave me some of
the icing he opened the door and he was
laughing and as soon as he was laughing
I ran in the bathroom and I took a [ __ ]
and wash my hands sorry I don't even
have time to say no cuz I think the man
first thing he said the men I opened the
drum oh what's up Jordan egos all think
I was gonna shine your driveway the
first greeting
[Laughter]
think of it I'm [ __ ] nosy - oh yes I
have a tooth it just cut it off right
before he smelled his ass no but you see
his head and going into it we have he'll
a funny surveillance footage so upstairs
were Tycho sleeping yesterday we're like
we're putting him asleep is like a
ticking time bomb
so we slowly like put him to sleep what
do you say we all the timing so you or
me because it's yeah it was me so it's
her and then she put she put him down
and when he's about to go to sleep like
you'll see two adult standing with that
night vision right and in the minute you
hear him like get up like both of us
just sprawl on the ground real clear
like a [ __ ] Rosa and then you see
this he like he cries morally and then
you'll see two adults [ __ ] like
armies and we're on the [ __ ] floor
and then you know how like night-vision
like your eyes are like this is they
just see two adults with two little
shiny beady eyes yeah yeah is there like
a collection of funny clip art is just
erase a lot of funny fun what can you
save it them I can save the clips yeah I
just don't think about tipping unless
it's like bad [ __ ] buddy I thought was
the scariest moment of my life
I've been through many scary moments but
that one was like [ __ ] I almost went on
your bushes thanks I think
and I was picturing this whole time like
me just [ __ ] and then his neighbor's
walking the dog and I'm like
your butt exploding yeah so we have two
rows of bushes right so the way our
house is it's our front doors here
there's a bush we park our cars here on
our driveway and then we have a big
truck so there's this other bush here
that's hidden I look to the one that's
been open yeah but he was right here
right in front of our door and I would
have been facing everyone oh why don't
you go to the hidden book I didn't have
time you saw oh there's no logic when
you have this is that man no I didn't
you know there's the two bushes I would
have gone right in the middle so I had
two bushes on my side like I'm sorry I
carry it on your Bush gave me where's
the hose I shouldn't yeah I would have
just sprayed it not what I smelled so
bad human [ __ ] smells bad it does I run
a smelt auction diarrhea yeah oh my god
diarrhea has like a real weird like it
gets up there it's a very sharp smell I
hate poopy smell it's like a shock
sometimes like when I poop in it smells
bad I'm just angry on my toilet flush
for yourself yeah why the [ __ ] -
courtesy flush flush while you're still
midship yeah doesn't it splatter it back
up
no because I feel like that swirls the
air in the air like this oh it gets rid
of the smell gets rid of you know well
thank you for you the poo pourri yeah
sometimes poo pourri gets his ass kicked
cuz like sometimes it's it's bad poke
out of it I'll sit there and I'm just
mad I'm like what the [ __ ] why would
this smell come out of a human it's so
bad but yeah only yeah I drink alcohol
you ever diarrhea so hard that once you
finish you get up and it's on the
[ __ ] toilet
and I'm like what you're doing
abstract art [ __ ] spray paint I feel
like it splashes so hard that it slides
back up I think that's what it's like
like a lot of babies like it goes up
their back yeah you know it's so weird
to with like like food to like I haven't
had a bad bowel since I started eating
healthy and that's the shittiest part
about that because I know the foods that
I want it's gonna [ __ ] me up anyways
yeah yeah so wild like just eating
healthier I haven't had a single bad
bowel movement in like four house and
you used to get it all the time all the
[ __ ] time it was like a war zone I
didn't know it taking time bomb see
that's I got the reverse of that cuz I
usually eat like really healthy I eat a
lot of like fruits and vegetables and
like whole foods and stuff and so in
Mexico
I didn't eat healthy it always having
french toast every morning I was eating
food he loves you I was drinking rice
and beans yeah and and it was just my
stomach was like what the [ __ ] like this
is not the food we consume yeah but
that's why you had like the diarrhea's
yes I'm saying yeah that's for me like I
can't eat that if I eat that type of
food in the excess I'm gonna get [ __ ]
up for sure yeah but it's all worth it
don't man sometimes it is sometimes it's
not man cuz there's like times like what
I'm taking a [ __ ] and literally like it
gets the point cuz I grew up in a
Christian family like I'm stop talking
Ukraine to God praying to God I'm like
why whoa well I'm a good person
like why do I think I'm a good person
why do what why is this happening I'm
like grabbing at everything I've done
that when I drink too much like you
drink too much in the room is spinning
and you're just comedy in the toilet
like I've definitely done that or like
just make it stop spinning and throwing
up because the last time that happened
to me I was eating ramen and I had like
two packs in one go oh
it constipated me so bad I just started
crying out to God I was like please I'll
be the best Christian ever those ramen
packs they're [ __ ] Liars it's so it's
one bag but they always say it's
supposed to be two servings yeah it's
two servings so technically you have
forces this amount of amount of calories
and junk in it they're like this should
really be the [ __ ] split times it by two
because I found that out when I was
doing macros that my very first time
like six years ago
[ __ ] hack it was like 280 right but
it's two servings so is 560 so I had
about like Omaha mana calories yeah and
I didn't know yeah not worth it for two
pegs of ramen yeah and I was like what
the [ __ ] am I so bloated
yeah I love ramen
easily I love it like if Bart dies I
marry her I can't have instant ramen
anymore which are you talking about
though the Korean stuff to the cup or
the direct the square when I grew up on
that so that's like all I eat I would
loved it and I brown or the cotton
strumming like all of us and then after
having real like Japanese ramen I was
like oh it's different though because
like I still like I've even made ramen
you know I mean it's good that's the
other thing but you have Korean ramen
packets they're [ __ ] blah yeah I
don't even consider it ramen I just
consider it instant noodle cuz I like
taste now it's like all those salts my
na cuz it's like Taco Bell Mexican food
is not the same yeah it's still Taco
Bell for some reason now I'm just like
nah that's better for you have you had
the Korean ramen that's why this is the
one you have your house the [ __ ] lime in
black yeah so [ __ ] good dunno I never
eat it I just look at it and I dream eat
you're on instant ramen oh we have that
you want that we got that
kite on the plane no love the kind on
the plane that's like that the kind on
the plane I never had is the ramen on
the business class like if you're doing
international flights in between the
meals if you get hungry which I'm always
off on the eating schedule I can always
get hungry in between you can go up
there and they always have cups of
noodles
Oh instead or at least I guess I've
always flown to Southeast Asia so maybe
that's why but like I want to do that
yeah it's so good I didn't even know I
flew to Singapore once on business I
don't even know you could ask for more
food oh yeah oh you didn't have to ask
you go up to the walk-up bar they had
like a walk-up snack bar at the alcohol
bar yeah you know cuz they kept giving
me so much food I didn't even have time
to ask for more cuz like I'll be likely
as soon as I laid down they come out
with chicken satay
I'm like whoa as soon as I lay down it's
like what your meals gonna be what right
I was in cochon Singapore and they still
did that they were still doing tons of
wine alcohol like whatever you want ice
cream Japan right Singapore yeah we did
yeah yeah and the little outfits I love
their outfits they got a little hat yeah
no one panic mm-hmm Singaporeans
just dress really nice they do I always
I felt like a scrub there well you know
who are the worst dressers in the world
[ __ ] Taiwanese people and they all
dressed like Jason Chen it's a
flesh-colored sauce like I've never
unless their ball in than the pollen was
adult I've never been to a country where
people majority the people didn't give a
[ __ ] about that it's still kind of off
it they look like they look like wannabe
Japanese people close to Japan right and
so they get the Japanese fashion
influence but they don't do it right
they don't know how to do that they
don't know how to do it right so they'll
take paper or whatever hot stuff and
it's just yeah I I was like there and I
was like how come not a single person is
dressed decently and they would have
expensive [ __ ] but it's like just cuz
you have expensive [ __ ] doesn't mean it
looks good yeah you know what I mean
it's like mismatched exactly yeah you
still gotta take a shower - exactly so
some cats go help like buy $300 hat and
is this [ __ ] Greece coming out
do you got to take a shower man can we
all just go to Taiwan together I love
the food there the boot Challenger
though I haven't seen one fashionable
person I feel like they always have like
these polo shirts that are really small
and then like for some reason like it's
90 degrees outside what's the crazy
[ __ ] is it a religious thing maybe it's
just really you're used to their climate
yeah so night like like 80 degrees is
like wintertime yeah they're like 80 to
100 or something you went during winter
which was like January which is exact
they're like are you cold
there's people with [ __ ] scarves and
[ __ ] I'm like [ __ ] it's like 75 degrees
was like don't leave the house without a
jacket I'm like what I'm swaggin she has
[ __ ] mittens on his [ __ ] Californians
are on the East Coast I'll be East
Coasters are like why are you so bundled
up dude like straight up man like I
remember cuz I was wearing like the Gulf
broke shirts whatever flip flops is
shorts and the lady who's making like
the buzz the meat buns became here
they'd be suffering dude oh they're
they're suffering with my relatives come
here and they come purposely in the
summer they're complaining about how
cold it is all the time so what about
winter they don't ever come in during
the winter so my family's from the south
so like their winter is like 80 85 maybe
that's where 85 degrees over yeah what
think really hockey yeah where do they
feel like all finally I could take my
jacket off like 120 what the humidity is
like Florida humidity too it's like well
like if you ever went to Taiwan in the
summer the minute the airplane door
opens when you feel like you walked into
like jello
fight through the air now so when they
do hot yoga they're just doing yoga yeah
feel like it's cold in here I don't
think even Florida's a good comparison
I think Taiwan is way more humid it's
[ __ ] thick yeah you go oh oh you have
to breathe like I will say this though
like if you have like dry skin or
something you're not gonna have that at
all
Michael went away that's tang i think
i'm meant to live in a [ __ ] jello box
yeah we went to it when we went to hong
kong goes in june and it was like really
hard to breathe oh yeah Hong Kong's
humid to hong kong it says bad air -
yeah with the smog and you make small
human oh wasn't then they can that hong
kong every day doesn't that a story here
yeah they can breath the air in a can
they have like paris la was from
different cities because I remember
Canada I don't know okay right Taiwan
has hella bad air too if you go during
the summer it's human and it's like this
muggy you'll produce like 10 times more
eye boogers and you never do like I'm
just [ __ ] walking around everywhere
does that's [ __ ] I'm burgers coming
out - it was a Bangkok that was the
first time I experienced that right when
we left the airport the [ __ ] whole
town was just smoke and humidity so it's
just trapped so you just smell exhaust
everywhere you go yeah like this is so
interesting like when you go to Asian
countries like how much emphasis they
put on like when I went to go get tea
right my person could speak Korean
Japanese Chinese and like French yeah
they all know so many like yeah I was in
Taipei and so the lady she just talked
to she spoke to she was picking me is
hurting this wasn't that great and she
goes are you Korean and they start
speaking in Korean like completely
fluent the entire funds like that and
Taipei - yeah they all they're all
trained to learn like four or five
languages cuz people travel so much
around there yeah yeah this crazy you
should throw me off and this shoot was
speaking French to somebody else and
came back I was like what the [ __ ] do
you think anywhere in America is like
that cuz then you're up to they know so
many language yeah you know that's
that's the biggest thing about traveling
that I learned is like my damn America
really doesn't give a [ __ ] about surahs
because how about went to Europe and I
was like how we're gonna get from the
airport oh there's just trains
everywhere that can take you anywhere
you want to go to your destination and
then you go to LA and I feel so bad for
Europeans now that go to LA cuz there is
nothing to take you anywhere you got to
pay a hundred bucks minimum for a taxi
or an over to because you go I went all
through Europe and there's trains at
every Airport that take you just where
you want to go and then maybe you take a
taxi for like two minutes from the train
stop Taiwan's train stations super easy
compared to Japan's like Oh God like
towns like I guess like when Mariel
lived there from then that she goes oh
they opened up two more new railways or
whatever but so it was even smaller than
what I saw before because I was used to
seeing Tokyo [ __ ] and that [ __ ] was
confusing his [ __ ] man Toki was easy
though what yes she was confusing I had
to use the Google map [ __ ] cuz there
were so many stops like I was easy oh
good it's smaller it's waste much it's
the circle Singapore was really cool to
take the train on because everywhere you
got off it we looked really beautiful go
on [ __ ] casino things yeah the pool
like it's called magic sands or
something like that
infinity pool it's an infinity pool no
roof and it's the roof is huge so it's a
skyscraper I'm just afraid of breaking a
law yeah you can't chew gum and you have
a lot of fans in Singapore or not dude
Singapore's dope I want to go there what
other laws can't you break well we can't
afford a pub later I read up on them so
we are asked yeah they're very clean and
if you litter or like you chew gun at
all anything like that it's like a
thousand dollar fine and then if you
can't pay it you go to jail can you pick
your boogers off like you know you don't
even do that no why just checking just
just don't do it cuz it's still Chinese
people does have class just just because
it's called a different country doesn't
change the way time people have I don't
know if it's that kind of Chinese though
cuz they're so strict about like
everything you
now enforcing this I don't I didn't see
them but I'd barely like walked around
me I was only there for like three days
they don't have cops they have guys
dressed up in [ __ ] plants and [ __ ]
come on you to come but that was super
humid there because it was raining yeah
I just want to eat the food there's one
girl that eat food just prayin
Molly has the best food so we did Bali
Indonesian food Bali has the best food
I've ever tasted in my life I dream
about that food Steve told us that
you're making in the smoker be nice
sweating so much really I wonder though
like in certain cases like for cuz we're
so blessed to have like such great food
in LA yeah cuz there's like food out
here that like I've had it in other
countries participate
yeah you know fish and chips is the best
in Pasadena yeah when I first went to
London I tried maybe like 20 or 30
restaurants and the best is in Pasadena
it's because they come here and they
innovate whatever the culture they came
from is like in in England it's like
we've had this recipe for hundreds of
years and it's like what maybe it's time
to change it people have come up with
better [ __ ] so far yeah it's also too
like we just have better produce better
cows we just have access to a lot more
stuff happy cows come from California
yeah but good tasting cows come from
Texas
[Music]